Tuscany. Why don't you put salt in your bread?
I have a few theories. One is that Florence is
kind of far from the coastline, so they
didn't have access to salt. That doesn't
really hold up. There's a lot of inland places
that have salt in their bread. Another theory is
that all the food eaten in this area is so extra
salty that eating it with bread, with no salt is
actually like it balances it all out. Although,
there's lots of other parts of Italy that also
eat similarly salty food, but they still put
salt in their bread. The last theory is the
Salt War. Back in like 1540, the Pope raised
taxes on salt in one important Italian city,
and the people were like, “%$@# that, we'll
just stop salting our bread.” “Oh, and now
we're independent, Pope!” And the Pope was like,
“that's cute.” And had his army swiftly crush the
rebellion. So now saltless bread is a tradition
carried on in the name of defiance. But again,
this story revolves around a specific city. And
saltless bread is found all over Tuscany. Plus,
there's not a ton of historical evidence
supporting this sudden change in bread baking. And
there's references to saltless bread in Tuscany,
like hundreds of years before the Salt War. So,